the mayor of Maui will not say how many
children are missing what we've been
told is that officially there are about
100 people who have died in the fires
but there are a thousand people missing
missing now how many days later here's
where the mayor of Maui has to say I
don't know yes you do
how many children are missing
you know I knew the answer to that I
would be happy to answer that you have
no estimate as to how many children are
missing nothing around this right now
[Music]
every time
an illegal alien child at the border
caught a cold during the Trump
Administration it was National headline
news AOC pretending to cry outside the
gates but a thousand people potentially
dead in Maui many of them if not most of
them children and nothing nothing a
media blackout